a local teen is graduating a year early
with honors from the top charter school
in the nation jeremy j ford spoke with
her and her family and shares her
incredible story tonight
i want people to see that through all
the adversities and challenges that they
can still make it on thursday keila
johnson will graduate with honors from
southeast career technical academy but
she says because of covid it wasn't an
easy task with the pandemic and me
graduating my junior year i didn't get
the chance to apply for any scholarship
her mother kiana johnson is proud of her
daughter and says her success is just
the beginning she dealt with a lot of
hardships she dealt with a lot of
challenges in her life like almost
losing her mother and co-parenting her
little brother when i first got to this
school freshman year my mom had a heart
attack that caused me to stay home from
school to watch my brother he's on the
spectrum he has autism but words of
encouragement enabled her to stay strong
and keep going she told me
just focus and she did graduating early
with a 3.6 gpa i want to see keala
continue with her success if you would
like to support kiela's journey to
college you can find the link to her
gofundme on our website at eight newsnow
dot com in las vegas jeremy j ford live
local now